and our zip code of the day today 80203
shout out to denver colorado
that's right hello denver
home of our affiliate station kc nc
cbs4 now denver is nicknamed the mile
high
city because it sits exactly one mile
above sea level
the denver mint produces about 40
million coins
a day and about 70 percent of that
are pennies i love pennies especially
picking up lucky pennies heads up on the
street
it holds the second largest gold bullion
deposit in the u.s
holding 100 billion dollars worth of
solid gold
bars denver colorado we would love to
hear from you
please send us some mail okay now let's
get started we're going to read our
first letter
just so you know i open these for the
first time on air
makes it more fun okay let's see
dear drew and crew
hello ashley from the druseum here oh
the jerusalem is this wonderful museum
about me
which is weird because i don't know why
anyone would want to do that but
here i have been enjoying the show so
very much
my daughter and i were lucky enough to
be vff's a few weeks ago um she was
inspired and wanted to send drew some
artwork she asked me what's drew's
favorite thing besides children and i
promptly answered mac and cheese
ashley you know me so well so that was
the motivation behind her cute drawing
that we've enclosed and we hope you
enjoy it
first of all ashley don't be a stranger
we've hung out many times
okay mila thank you so much
and i will be framing this and it will
be going on my wall
in fact let's see here why don't we just
put it up right now even though i hate
putting a hole in it but
i can fix that later okay oh god hold on
look i love it
thank you mila and ashley thanks guys
okay our second letter is
here we go i'm old 64.
that's not old for one of my first
retirement adventures
i'd like to find and explore some mining
properties that howard hughes owned
and frequented i purchased a retirement
motorcycle
cool and a jeep for these adventures but
could use a new state-of-the-art metal
detector to find howie's artifacts
could you help i'll split them with you
first of all of course lance campbell
from uh jackson california i am inspired
by your plan so i'm sending you a
thousand dollars
so you can get that metal detector of
your dreams
and start your own adventures i'm so
happy for this chapter of your life
by the way there is one request will you
send us some pictures and updates and
keep in touch
okay thank you um we have time for one
more
and this is from trish ramall in
sheboygan wisconsin
um dear drew i actually have a recipe
box with actual recipe cards
i love them and i've shared them with
many people and i ran out
of people to give recipes to so tag
i like your style anyway i can't believe
you never ate spam
sent you a favorite recipe for mac salad
with spam
maybe you can test it on the show i hope
you like it
love trish okay these recipes
are absolutely gorgeous
i absolutely will cherish these thank
you so much
this is treasure thank you i'm really
glad that you
spammed me get it you're spamming my
mailbox
but i'm not upset because you included
these wonderful recipes and this
absolute treasure i love them
i have been wanting to try spam again
what's this thank you paulie
wait what
oh my gosh and like at
macaroni salad you sent the recipe
so we made it mmm
[Music]
trish oh no you did it
it's so good recipe mac salad
here it is okay trish one pound rotini
frozen peas
miracle whip that's the taste i
love it yellow mustard apple cider
vinegar sugar
thank you so much thank you trish okay
if any of you guys out there want advice
help
maybe you want to try something new mail
me your questions requests photos
funny or heartfelt stories and to find
out more
get our address go to the drewberrymore
show.com
dear drew i can't wait to read more of
your letters
live on the show ashley and mila and
lance and trish thank you so much for
your letters
and here are my postcards to you
that okay
truly yours true